breaking with tradition again together
we must protect cherish and defend the
dignity and the sanctity of every human
life Donald Trump descended on
Washington's National Mall to personally
address an anti-abortion rally
making him the first sitting US
president to do so again affirming his
support for their cause
unborn children have never had a
stronger defender in the White House the
March started in response to the
landmark 1973 Supreme Court ruling
legalizing abortion a divisive issue in
the United States
Trump's 2016 promised to appoint Supreme
Court judges who might overturn that
ruling helped him win the White House
with the help of these supporters for
many the issue is personal the unborn do
not have a voice and we are their voices
we are their voices they're being killed
by the midden but the president also
needs many of these people who consider
themselves evangelical voters to show up
in this November's presidential election
and they need him to I Neal M for such
the US president kept his 2016 promise
to evangelical voters naming
conservative justices Neal Gorsuch and
later Brett Kavanaugh to America's
highest court altering its balance to
make it a more conservative bench with
Democratic appointees Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsberg's health in decline Trump's
anti-abortion supporters are eyeing a
possible third conservative court
appointment Trump wins reelection it's
critical the country if you really study
it you study our Constitution the
founding of the country it was founded
on judeo-christian beliefs and we need
to return to that we have so many judges
and so many things are changing and we
need to have that pro-life person placed
in there so that we can continue what
we're doing we come before you lord but
Trump's had to work to keep socially
conservative voters on his side he
organized this rally earlier this month
in Miami to energize even
chuckles after an article in magazine
Christianity today published an
editorial calling for his removal from
office citing Trump's grossly immoral
character he's going into re-election in
a weakened state right now and what he
needs more than anything is his base and
I think what we're seeing with this
president is recognizing without them he
there he has no shot of actually getting
reelected as the u.s. election campaign
gains momentum expect even more appeals
by President Trump to his religious base
as he continues to make the case he is
the only candidate who will defend their
faith Kimberly Hellcat al Jazeera the
White House